[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money your life
your relationships your mental health we
talk about everything on this show i'm
john delonie joined here by ramsey
personality george campbell and we are
taking your calls on everything give us
a shout at triple eight eight two five
five two two five it's triple eight
eight two five five two two five george
how we doing brother so good this is my
my third show this week and we're just
getting started it's our second time
co-hosting this week
that's it you realize that it's like
groundhog day
or it's just the state of america and if
you're listening right now you're going
this is a double blessing george and
john twice that's what they're saying
that's what they call it
nope they're trying to reach over for
the uh the scan button to see if anybody
else is they haven't listened long
enough to even hear this at that at that
point that's exactly right it's fine but
we're here for you we would love to
answer your questions and if you're a
millennial
uh or gen z and you forgot that there's
a phone app on your phone this is crazy
if you tap that and you dial 888 825
you will be patched through to jenna who
would be happy to put you through to us
and jen is a human she's a real person
yep not an app if they could figure out
a way to automate that they probably
would kelly would be like i'm out of
here retirement let's do this yeah
probably not i think kelly would destroy
the internets
the robots or whatever fair point what
have you been up to john you've been
traveling a whole bunch yeah we've been
on the road um you are hanging out with
the minimalists not long ago businesses
and yeah we're all over the place man
talking about mental health and
relationships and you've been heads down
i can i'm gonna tease this you've been
working really hard on a new book yeah
it comes out in looks like in april and
it is
i'm excited for it me too this the
challenge is going to be trying to
convince people that there's mental
health and relationship challenges going
on in the world right now i don't know i
think they need convincing john they do
not i assure you no it's cool man if you
could ever have a
book coming out on a subject and the
world through you just an underhand
softball pitch man this is the scene can
you give us any level of tease because i
know you have been very intentional
about this book making sure that it does
connect making sure that you say what
you want to say and this is a it's a
tough process writing a book yeah um i
at the end of the day
dave tells a story um
about
he was coming out of one of his earliest
earliest financial peace
courses right he was walking out of a
building one evening and he had his book
and
a woman thumbed through it and she
looked at him and said finally
a finance book that i can actually
understand and he said that was the
moment that i realized that people with
all the letters after their names they
talk over people they talk at people
and
this woman was so grateful just to have
a book she could understand and she just
heard a conversation that she could
understand
not in a
like demeaning way but in a everyone
tries to over intellectualize everything
and so the guiding principle of this
book was i think what we know about
mental health is
nonsense i think that the world has set
us up to fail and blamed us for it and
so
this is finally a mental health and
relationship book that people can
understand that actually
will say here's the challenge not this
and not this not this and so yeah i'm
tired of seeing people all over the
country actually i've been on the road
i'm meeting with people big groups
little groups
groups of uh
businesses individuals
i'm tired of people saying i'm broken
something's wrong with me
and getting plugged back into the matrix
here and it's just it's time that we
stop and it's the same dave went after
debt 30 years ago and here we are and
i'm going after that whoo that's going
to be so good i'm real excited to change
the tune i appreciate that man and i can
read it
it's on my level
the font will be big okay thank you size
16. it'll be in 16.4 well you have an
interesting story john because this is
rooted out of your own personal
experience on top of uh your education
background you've got two phds you have
many many years decades in this world
counseling people um trying to help in
crisis situations and people's darkest
moments you're the guy who runs in yeah
yeah and so well and
there's this there's a lot of inside
baseball right and counseling and
therapy and psychology has become this
mystical world and psychiatry and all
the medicines and all the
um all the different types of counseling
and thoughts and i'm broken and i've got
this diagnosis and so i can only do this
and i can never do that nonsense and so
it's time to just turn the lights on
stop the music and say what are we doing
right and we got to acknowledge man the
world shifted underneath us real real
fast right stuff that was nuts 50 years
ago like you'd never borrow money unless
it was the last possible option and you
knew you were chaining yourself to
something
now we do not talk a class
i'm gonna buy a t-shirt on payments
brother it's cool man right and so the
same with mental health and uh here's a
fun story a few years ago i was a part
of a brain study we did out of some
fancy university where they were giving
us all this stuff and all these tests
and
they took us in the back room and
they're like all right so we've computed
this and done all this and
here's the findings right the seven
magical things
for brain health
and i walked out of there holding this
piece of paper and i remember going
my grandmother specifically told me six
of these when i was a small small child
and she didn't go to college and she
how we spent a trillion billion
gajillion dollars
to loot back around to stuff that my
grandmother told me and so the lives
that we're leading are nuts they're out
of control the businesses that we're
trying to run the the homes that we're
trying to run the our marriages are
parenting it's bonkers and somebody's
got to say stop stop and there's another
way to do this man and really it's
rooted in this idea dude i'm worth more
than that you're worth more than that my
wife is worth more than that my kids are
worth more than that
and i'm taking these calls on my show
every single day
of people just melting
and they're doing the best they can with
the tools they got they're leading the
best they can they're trying to love
their husbands the best they can trying
to parent the best they can
and the only tools we have right now is
go faster and go harder and do it more
and it's not working man so you tell
people slow down and take control of
what you can take control of yeah and
you talk about this a lot two things you
can take control of your thoughts and
your actions not that you can that's all
you can that's all that's it that's the
game that's the game and it's
disorienting because we want to flex and
scream and yell and grabs control so
much more and i mean you can i mean you
could you can do that for me it's so
much easier to focus on what's out of
control though john that's what makes
headlines exciting well it makes me buy
stuff right when i think oh i could just
get the right candle with the right
scent in the right
this and the right bathtub and the right
shiplap and the right whatever that's
gonna solve my you know what i mean or
if i just get another girlfriend or
another drink or the right workout
program
um
then finally finally i'm going to be all
right and the deal is that's nonsense
man it's just nonsense so just a
reorientation um and i'm looking forward
to getting it out there but boy i'll
tell you what you know it's really sucks
editing it's oh man
i i have a lot of respect and love for
editors out there
it's not a job most normal people should
want so i'm grateful for the ones that
are out there doing it
well uh john i want people to take
control of a lot of areas of their life
i know you do too so if you've got a
question give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five maybe
you need some affirmation maybe you just
go i think i know what i need to do i
just needed someone to tell me yes
that's exactly right give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five yep we're trying to jinx that with
you i thought we were gonna have been
fun we should try it together back again
but uh no we're not doing that let's try
it james james is egging it on i've
refused to be a part of this nonsense
fine but relationships work money your
home parenting give us a shout triple
eight eight 825-5225 see how i snuck
that in there we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just thirty
dollars a month get unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month by switching to pure top
just go to puretalk.com and enter the
promo code ramsey to save 50 off your
first month pure talk simply smarter
wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm john dalony
joined by george campbell we are taking
your calls on life and money and
relationships and parenting triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to ethan in detroit michigan what's
up brother ethan how are we doing
doing well how are y'all doing
outstanding what's up how can we help
so my wife and i have been talking i
really have a desire to
build a house on some property
and my only issue is
my what would be the down payment
because from most of what i've
researched for a construction loan you
need about 20 down
is all tied up in my current houses
equity
my current house is around
i value probably around 250 on a great
day to go to 300 and i owe currently
about
110 on it
okay so you got about one 140 plus in
inequity
yes i'm curious
in terms of getting to where i can build
a new house
what would be the wiser decision
whether to sell this house and rent
closer to where we want to build and
that way i can kind of manage it and i
have that to put down
or if there's some other way i can
leverage the equity in my current house
without selling it
until the next house is ready the word
leverage just it puts uh i don't like it
the hair on my arm
hemorrhoids hey so you you have you have
a plan
why why don't you trust yourself with
that plan i like that plan
so
the tough part with that one is
looking at written everything
i'd be looking to go from my like 500 a
month mortgage to like 15 to 2 000 a
month to rent yeah and so i'm just
you know if it's actually going towards
a construction rate to put that from
month to month i feel better with that
sure but you go for a year or two
it hurts with the construction loan when
do you actually need to have that money
when you need to give them that money
i haven't talked to a specific banker
yet so most of this has been online
research but my understanding with the
construction loan was
up front you would need that 20 down
right okay that's my question is if
that's the case or if it's later on down
the road to where you could sell and
make it kind of a clean exchange uh when
you move out of that house have you
already bought this land ethan
no i haven't i would be in that worth it
this feels to me and george hopping here
this feels to me like a dream
that's still a few years away
that you've looked at the equity and
your house is
doing pretty well because the market's
lost its freaking mind
and you've got this dream of wanting to
buy land and build your dream house or
build a house on land
and there's a gap there
i have no problem man it's it's what me
and my wife did if you sell this house
you rent for a while until you can land
where you want to land
and i get the gap um i think what you're
trying to have is it have it all which
is you don't have 20 down to go ahead
and start this process without have
selling this house and you can't sell
this house if you're not renting and you
can't rent if it's not so you're going
to have to give on something if you want
to make this move right now
i'd love to see you save up like crazy
with a 500 mortgage over the next year
or two
um and then sell your house you risk not
having as much equity in it
and you also
that with that same risk you risk that
the land you're going to buy is going to
be cheaper too
and so it's six one way if those in
another man but it sounds like you're
just a few years off
um or you're trying to cram a future
dream into a right now moment but man if
you can pull the trigger and rent for a
few years um and get this thing done i i
george my experience has been people way
underestimated how long
getting on land getting the land perked
and getting the permits and getting the
the that's what worries me sewer
connected and it turns into a year or
two yeah not three years but a year or
two yeah it takes a while and do you
know how much the land plus construction
loan would cost right now
i'm that's the main probably around five
hundred thousand so my wife and i make
200
150 if she ends up staying home for the
next couple years i just had a daughter
recently
my tough part is
i bought a
bankruptcy cell house at the 125 years
old i fixed up pretty much there and to
be honest i'm just tired of it there you
go tired of looking at it you're ready
for something
yeah thank you for telling us that part
yeah you're ready to get out well you
got an incredible income and so if you
guys can live and you've got a 500
mortgage which tells me there's got to
be tons of margin in your budget right
you guys have any other debt
we have
yeah we have one auto debt which we have
the money in the bank i just have to
figure out the tax situation for the end
of the year
to make sure i don't overdo it i had to
change jobs this year
and so with that i had to buy two
vehicles and i was stupid on it so i
took it but
let's clean up all this debt we have the
money in the bank
we have the money in the bank it's just
i want to make sure i'm covered on taxes
well you can connect with the tax pro in
your area we've got those all over the
country in detroit you can go to
ramseysolutions.com but i don't want you
to be paralyzed by a decision here going
well i got to figure out the tax i got
to figure out this you make 200 grand a
year man put this thing to work pay off
all this consumer debt start stacking up
like crazy and you could have this down
payment for this land and construction
loan within a year on your income and to
piggyback off that ethan i want you to
sit down with an actual
contractor who could build this house
start getting some real numbers right
now you are
on the internet you're estimating here
you're estimating there sit with the
real
um endorsed local provider a real ramsey
trusted real estate pro that's going to
sit down and say here's what i can sell
your house for right now and then you
can have some very real numbers to begin
to create very real decisions and a very
real timeline right now it's just so
amorphous it's just spinning are you and
your wife gonna have two incomes or one
and what's what's the extra margin our
budget well we got this one loan i don't
know about taxes you need some clear
answers and some very clear specifics
lucky for you and this sounds like it's
a pitch but it's not
but it kind of is but you can do all
that at ramsey solutions.com you can get
tax info that you need you can get a
real estate person that you need you
can't get a construction loan i mean a
construction guy there but you can go
find someone in your area that can help
you with what is this thing going to
actually cost and then you can make a
game plan it feels like you're close but
not quite there but man i also get
i'm so sick of looking at this house i
gotta get out of this house man
let's go to ellen in chicago ellen
what's up
hey john how you doing hey how's it
going
well um
i'm calling because i um
my mom um
actually has dementia she um
she got really psychosepsis and because
she had a fall
um it was um not found for about 12
hours it had um
started her memory loss i'm so sorry um
so what i'm calling is that um
i'm big on family and i'm actually
struggling with my
mother-in-law uh when she came up i had
her stay at my mom's you know because
she was in assisted living at the time
and
she had started asking for
belongings from my mom and i just
honestly wasn't rice caps yep
so um
things had
somewhat escalated
um
just with her asking for things and
the pain is still there yeah and my
husband wants
you know they want to get together for
christmas and
honestly i
i don't want to but i also don't want
our kids to be
affected by it but
you know i want them to see
you know happy anytime but um
i'm really hurt by this yeah i can hear
that hurt in your heart and your voice
so you've got a family picture of
what the holidays are quote unquote
supposed to look like
you have
the grief that you're dealing with in
the everyday reality of dealing with
your mom and her challenges
and then you've got a mother-in-law
right in the middle of this and you and
mother-in-law got sideways because
mother-in-law was being inconsiderate
and
pretty disrespectful and
now we're trying to figure out how to
make all this work let's do this hang on
the line here we're going to hold you
over to a break and we can dig into this
a little bit deeper thank you so much
for being brave and for
letting us know what's going on and for
sharing with us
man there's a lot going on especially as
we head into the holidays george that
gets tough tough tough i'm so grateful
ellen called hey we'll be right back
right here on the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience
if someone from that company likes your
profile they can personally invite you
to apply for the job so if you're ready
for an easier job search check out
ziprecruiter sign up for free right now
at recruiter dot com slash ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show i'm john deloney
joined by george campbell taking your
calls on life and relationships and
money
how to get out of debt how to fix your
marriage triple eight eight two five
five two two five we are talking to
ellen in chicago and before the break
ellen i'm gonna recap this let me know
if i'm right or not
your mother has been struggling with her
health and recently was diagnosed with
dementia and she is currently
staying with you guys is that correct
she's actually staying with my sister
stay with your sister okay
and your mother-in-law moved in and
she was
uh
she came up for a visit oh okay for a
visit okay and for the for the
convenience of not spending for a hotel
we just had her stay at my mom's condo
at the time she was um
in a recovery center from uh her um from
her fall
gotcha yeah she had developed senses
yep okay so
your mother-in-law began asking hey
she's not going to use this stuff could
i have some of your mom's stuff
and
in a really insensitive way in a really
insensitive time that hurt you
and if you not spoken to your
mother-in-law since you've just stayed
apart from one another
yeah i've been very short with her on
the phone okay very short tell me about
how this hurts you
this has affected you in a way beyond
just a
well you're an idiot this is effect this
is hurt you tell me about that
because my mom's not dead yeah
and just what she was asking for were
things that were very important to my
mom yeah
does she know that she hurt you
my mother your mother-in-law
yeah i think so because
for a while um
my husband and i had
come outside to talk and i just
cried
yeah
a lot
and when it came back in she said
you know
if you want me to i'll leave rolly
and of course she said from the kids i
said no i mean you know they want to see
you
how much of this hurt
is
related to the incense insensitivity of
your mother-in-law and how much of this
hurt is just the weight
that your mom's hurting
and she is coming up on the end stages
of a remarkable life
well um just to kind of keep things a
little short i had mentioned um
okay
um i had mentioned to um the lady who
took the call that we had
argued over um
something and she had actually sent me
to a box of
of the item that really
it's not going to make sense i'm just
trying not to gross out anybody but um
i just she had done something i felt for
spite um but how much is the pain versus
um
well ironically my mother-in-law um lost
her mom to alzheimer's as well yeah
so i
i
sounds like
i get that
yeah it's a lot that's exactly right so
here's here's here's the we kind of
whittle it down
you get to decide
in partnership with your husband what
the holidays look like
and if you are
in a place in your heart and your mind
where your mother-in-law hurt you so
deeply you don't want her around
then you get to choose that all of us
get to choose that and that choice that
boundary comes with consequences
it comes with kids that don't get to
hang out with their grandmother and it
may be worth it
or it may be kids i'm not going to be a
part of it this year me and your father
are going to go do something else so be
it
all boundaries boundaries are never
clean there's always some mess to them
and people run up against those
boundaries to see if they hold
what i would love to see you do
if at all possible is to sit down with
your mother-in-law and say this request
hurt me
and maybe you didn't mean to but i want
you to know that it did and i'm not
ready to start giving away my mom's
thing she's still alive
and from this point forward i don't want
to talk about my mom's stuff
when that day comes then that day will
come but we're not there yet and that's
you taking ownership of the situation
and getting in front of it getting on
top of it and not letting it continue to
drown you does that make sense george
yeah
so
take ownership of that phone call that
phone call may be hard or you can meet
in person maybe you have to write out
what you're going to say i've done that
several times where i know i'm going to
be emotional about a conversation and i
write down what i want to say that way i
don't get my words don't get all jumbled
up i don't lose perspective and i say
what i need to say in a respectful way
in a dignified way and then let her
respond and my guess is she didn't try
to hurt you my guess is that
she probably was being insensitive but
she had no idea she's gonna cause this
kind of pain right yeah and holidays are
messy let's all remember when it comes
to holidays man we get to we get to make
a choice right we've talked about this
john on the entree leadership podcast
coming up on a fine print episode on the
holidays and spending
families boundaries there can be so much
that bubbles up yep especially around
this time uh which this just happened to
be some some poor timing here as we head
into the holidays but bitterness
resentment but you get to choose yeah
your response to it and ellen mike
my guess is
this may be the first
thanksgiving christmas without mom this
may be the first thanksgiving and
christmas
where the reality of dementia and
alzheimer's is setting in on the family
it's so hard ah it's such so hard
and then it gets it's easy to cast some
of that pain and some of that resentment
onto somebody who says the wrong thing
at the wrong time right so again do your
best to unbraid what's hurt what's real
what's it's all real but what what's
where's the hurt lie
and then be direct about addressing who
hurt you and then let's all move on
let's heal or let's make a boundary and
let's move on from there right
but i want you to take ownership of this
ellen and of all the different facets of
this thing and i know you can do it i
know you're hurting but i know you can
do it let's go to stacy in atlanta hey
stacy what's going on
hi
so i have a daughter who is a junior in
high school and we've been looking at
colleges and that means we're going to
be filling out the fafsa and as i was
researching all of that
she was gifted some stock by my father
her grandfather
back when she was a baby and then those
dividends were reinvested over time and
so she's looking with a small amount of
money i mean like maybe
twelve thousand dollars that she can use
for college
or however she wants to use it because
it's just stock but my question is
um to put her in the best position
financially like
for taxes and for getting financial aid
should i plan for her to cash in that
stock and pay it you know use it in the
first year do we do it over several
years or do we go ahead and put it into
a 529 or some other kind of education
plan just to put her in the best
position to get financial aid
um when that time comes i guess next
year or the year after
so she's about two years away from going
to college
yes and she's she'll be entering the
fall of 2023 okay
good for you for planning ahead that's
awesome so is she going to be able to go
through college debt-free regardless of
this stock or is this stock kind of
hinging on hey are we going to be able
to pay for college
um so as i'm looking at the colleges
that she is interested in
they are
around twenty thousand dollars a year
and um
so
no she doesn't have like it'll be
scholarships grants and then this
okay and that's some hoping right now we
don't have any of that and
we're hoping that we're going to get
some scholarships okay
i want her to choose the school based on
what what you guys can afford come up
with a plan together and scholarships
and grants can be a part of that but if
that falls through we still gotta have a
plan b
so if i'm you guys i'm gonna cash out
the stock and what i'm gonna do with it
like you said put it into an esa a 529
let that grow tax free you're probably
better off with a 529 if you've got a
good plan in your state you can look
into that you can connect with a
smartvestor pro in your area at
ramseysolutions.com they can help you
navigate this whole process and that's
going to let your money grow tax-free
for two years and she can use it on all
those education expenses so that'll set
her up nicely i also want you to stay on
the line we're going to send you a copy
of our friend anthony o'neill's book
debt-free degree and i want you all to
read that together and can we get her a
code to the documentary do those exist
stay on the line we're gonna get you a
code so that you don't have to pay for
you can watch our new borrowed future i
want you all to sit down as a family and
watch this
and let that
impact what colleges y'all are going to
choose to go to and how you take out
debt
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show taking
calls on life and money and
relationships let's go to laura in
portland oregon hey laura what's going
on
[Music]
well i was fired on friday ah i'm sorry
yeah
actually i'm looking forward to it being
the best thing that ever happened to me
i love it what happened
well
there was a new manager that came in in
january
and
she cleaned house pretty much put
everyone that had been there before her
you know on terrible mindless menial
tasks etc and i i was next my hair was
on the chopping block on friday so
i am 57 years old i have finally grown
out my full gray white hair so i look
like santa claus
and now i'm i'm up for looking for
another job and my biggest concern is
that i had a great professional career
all you know after college etc and i had
a horrible divorce that i went through
and
long story short my job um history had
some gaps in it and this company i
worked for for seven years they're
basically my only
reference that i can use and
they fired me so now i'm like i've got
no confidence my faith is a little bit
shaky
and i have outdated skills so
um i've got the financial loss the
stress um i was trying to get debt free
and yeah so any advice would be helpful
yeah that's a lot so
do me a favor can you just inhale real
deep and hold your breath for a second
take a big deep breath and just hold it
three
two now let it out
can we just all say i need to help this
sucks i'm sorry
it does yeah it's it's a lot
um our my friend coleman we were talking
about some research the other day that
losing a job
is can be as devastating psychologically
as losing a loved one
yeah and you put on top of that you're
still
wrestling with a divorce how long ago
was that
uh that was 2006. okay so that's still
fresh in your soul there though
pretty much yeah it was
2013 i had a
nervous breakdown basically and
got back into life after that so yeah so
yeah this is your first big stress test
since the last nervous breakdown of the
things you learned about yourself and
some tools right and here we are
and
yes you're driving down the highway and
the car's starting to rattle on you a
little bit and you remember this your
body remembers this
so
what were you doing what was your job
um i was working on a government
contract doing scanning of um
department of human services files like
child abuse cases adoptions etc so i
would prep all those files removing
staples paperclips etc sure put them
into the scanner and then scan them
index it export it to see it etc so what
is this nonsense about you have outdated
skills you can't call our show and not
tell us the truth you know what you're
doing you can do cool stuff
well i used to in my previous life i was
a trade show manager for a high-tech
company and did trade shows all over the
world basically okay
laura you've told me two different
things and i wanna
can i call you out a little bit even
though we're in front of a couple of
dozens you're welcome billion people
you've told me about your
past job about who you used to be yeah
about your past marriage who used to be
yes and i wanted you to put a period at
the end of those sentences
because we have to deal with today
and just because you used to run trade
shows and then you went to preparing
documents for
child abuse cases and
adoptions
there is no difference in importance you
may have made more money than one and
one may have been flashier
but both jobs are necessary
and the next job you get is going to be
necessary
and just because some guy walked out on
you and said something else is better
than
laura who's my new friend by the way
is reflective of his actions not yours
yeah
one of the demons
one of the hallmarks of depression is we
keep trying to pull the past
back into the present with us
and we we want to say this is the way
it's always been this is the way it's
always going to be i'm going to do
something else i'm going to get involved
in another job another relationship and
that's going to leave me too
and i want to shift that narrative and
say
man we got a new manager
phooey
next
right
yes
i'm freaking laura with long awesome
gray hair and i'm 57. i can do anything
i want to
so here's the question not
how do i get back to what was because
that's gone the question is what do i do
next so what do you do next what do you
want to do laura you're 57. you're
almost halfway i can see you living to
be 115. so you're about halfway what do
you want to do
well ideally i would like to find a job
that pays my bill well enough that i can
foster a puppy for a local organization
that gives service dogs to our veterans
with ptsd
i think you can make so i just need to
support myself so you just want to
afford a puppy
yeah i want to foster a puppy for a
veteran but what do you want to do with
like your work like your life
um i would like to get back into high
tech
or work in a marketing department
probably not as the lead marketing
person that goes out to see customers
but
more behind the scenes with the
marketing support
um
preferably for a high-tech company or a
um
like a chemical engineering company so
do you know anybody who works in high
tech or in kim and kim that you could go
sit down and have coffee with
i do know a couple people in high tech
good then today
and tomorrow you are promising us say i
promise
i promise that you're going to reach out
to those people
directly and say hey can we do coffee
and then you're going to say management
restructured and here i am and i want in
y'all's building how do i get in
and i will make copies i can prepare
documents
or i can run the whole show like i've
done
i can do it all i don't know a lot about
high tech i'm 57 i've got gray hair
they can just get over it because i'm
coming full laura
exactly okay so here's what i want you
to do two things two important things
number one
i want you to every time the past comes
up
i want you to take a deep breath
and exhale and say
thank god it's today
and you're gonna you may do that a
thousand times in your first day and a
thousand times in the second day third
day fourth day we're going to turn your
dial not from the past but to today and
we're going to begin looking forward
the second thing is is george asked a
great ques like
what do you want to do you want to go
work for a high-tech company that's
fantastic
i'm going to reach out and start making
some of those connections like our
friend the proximity principal i got to
get in i got to get in the door and i
know some people in those areas um real
real quick because we're up against the
clock
you got enough money to pay bills for a
couple of weeks
for a couple of months where are a
couple
you may need you may need laura to run
down and get a job at a coffee shop
to pay bills
and there's no shame in that game you
may need to run down to a local um
whatever and they are hiring like crazy
and find a job that's going to pay you
bills while you
bridge the gap between where you are now
and where you're going to end up
and you can get yourself that puppy stay
on the line we're going to give you a
copy of our friend ken coleman's brand
new book from paycheck to purpose walk
into the seven steps to get the career
you love and by the way
it doesn't matter if you're 27 or 57
it's not too late it's not too late and
hey we'll go ahead and get you a copy of
his assessment so you can walk through
and say once i get into this big tech
big kim what do i actually want to do
that would be fantastic right
man george that's big time
she's spirited laura's a stunt she's
going to make it happen make it happen
that's one hour oh what do you say i
just want to make sure we go to that
foster puppy john we'll get we'll get
that foster puppy just not a french
bulldog hey thanks to james and to kelly
for running the show today
ladies and gentlemen we'll be right back
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsey
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money
and your life your relationships your
marriage your parenting everything i'm
john deloney joined here by ramsey
personality george campbell triple eight
eight two five five two two five we are
taking your calls on everything george
how are we doing so good good i'm just
happy to be here john just grateful
today as i hear that intro music you're
like pinch me moment you know i'm
sitting here with dr john deloney
hosting the ramsay show this is a big
moment for you huge
huge and the second time this week and
i'm not going to pinch you that'd be
rude no you're really strong i just i
can tell you work out maybe crossfit
a huge fan i know you love huge fan
let's go to jessica in phoenix hey
jessica what's going on
hey how's it going outstanding how are
you so
uh you know what i'm doing amazing today
thank you excellent what's up
so
as you guys know maybe i don't know if
you're baseball fans but the world
series is happening and it's braves vs
astros
which is my husband's all-time two
favorite teams and his best friends and
i have the opportunity to potentially
send them to a game
but the financial decision
in that is what i'm trying to figure out
like if it's a good choice or not
because we have money saved up
we have an investment started the only
debt that i have is my student loans
and so i'm just trying to get like a
second opinion of like this may never
happen again the astros versus you know
the brave so is this something worse
saying forget it let's just do it
anyways or what do you guys think
oh you walked right into one so jessica
i was born and raised in houston
i have the astros logo tattooed on my
forehead i just covered up with makeup
just for the show
i even took a year off after the big
cheating incident like i sat down with
my yeah he was nine-year-old son we took
a year off
then we talked about redemption and now
we're back
so this is a big moment for me here's
what i will tell you what happened in my
life um a friend of mine is an executive
there with the astros and said i can get
you
discounted tickets and they were for me
uh 300 something dollars i was gonna i
had a whole plan i was gonna take my son
again this is never gonna happen again
i'm gonna i'm gonna here's my plan i was
gonna drive him
to school
and then go past the school and be like
dad you missed it and then i was going
to flash him the tickets we're going to
hop on a plane fly to houston it's going
to be amazing i was going to stay at a
friend's house i had it all planned out
and then i saw the cost of the tickets
and then i saw the cause to the flights
and then i thought i started doing the
math on the meals and the this and that
end of this
and so what i'll tell you in my house
i'm not in baby step two anymore
blown past baby step two i don't know
anybody any money and the cost for me
even was not gonna do it this year
we're gonna watch it on big tv we're
gonna have a blast we're gonna eat my
own food and we're gonna make a big
to-do of it
that's just me and i i don't know what
kind of fan he is he's not a bigger
astros fan than me i promise you
now i i mean i don't know i'm just
assuring you you're
you're wrong george you helped with the
money thing here okay jessica i heard
you say a lot of things that were
concerning to me
the sports things aside okay we can make
amends on that part john we cannot but
on the financial side you said we're
investing some and the only thing i just
i just have this little student loan
debt i only have one debt and you were
very quick to kind of brush all the
financials aside and get very excited
and i understand the excitement
but you said are you currently investing
right now is that right
well
yeah so we we have our roth iras set up
and then i have
i sold my house and so we have the money
from the sale of that house set aside
and we've changed our lifestyle
completely so we can continue to save
and so we sold everything we renovated a
fifth wheel and we're living super super
cheaply
okay well you said you said we're on the
baby steps is it okay to buy world
series tickets and in the baby steps we
teach that you only start investing once
you have paid off all of your consumer
debt and you have a fully funded
emergency fund so where are we at on
that side
and i have a fully funded emergency fund
and i just have student loans so that's
the debt that you have the cash to pay
off the student loan today
all but like five probably about five
thousand of it yeah so what happened
with the sale of the house i thought
this was you made a ton of money off of
this
i didn't make a ton i just made enough
that like i could pay off all of my
student loans
and my other debt so i took care of all
the highest interest yet and now that
jessica
we just keep running into first you're a
braves fan and now this okay hold on
we don't teach you to pay off the
highest interest at first you got to do
the debt snowball so you feel the
progress
so that the next time the braves and the
astros in the world series you're out of
debt and you can actually do this and do
it with confidence and not set
yourselves back so how much is left on
the student loan debt
um i have like fifty thousand
fifty thousand and how much do you have
in cash in your savings account checking
account
okay and part of that is your fully
funded emergency fund
crap and so you you're doing the the
jessica plan where we go all right we're
gonna get the fully funded emergency
fund but keep the student loan pet
around while we invest in the roth ira
and we're gonna watch a lot of hgtv so
we have a renovated fifth wheel so we
are living okay cool
and doing our own plan here's the deal
jessica i want to send you guys the
world series i wish i could just send it
say it on air we're gonna send you guys
we're not doing that but here's what i
can tell you to do i can tell you
congratulations you could have a paid
off student loan today
and you could have five thousand dollars
in a savings account which is gonna get
you towards a fully funded emergency
fund and to do all of that we're gonna
pause investing if this is gonna take
any more than a few months so that we
can speed up this process you've just
been doing a lot of you've been doing a
lot of nice good things but we're just
doing them out of order and you haven't
been seeing the progress that you could
have been seeing if you had done all
this in order so on this on the sports
side how much i'm just curious how much
is this whole thing going to cost if you
did this the the uh
well
there's different options but i have
also done the numbers like you guys said
and i would say that if i was gonna send
his best friend with him too it would be
about two thousand dollars
so you have fifty thousand dollars in
student loan debt but you have the
opportunity to send them on a two
thousand dollar trip and you're living
your trailer that you live in will lose
that much of depreciation over the
weekend
but who knows if they'll ever play each
other again like that's where i was at
who knows if we all live on space one
day here's what i do know every single
month you're sending your payment to a
lender and they're stealing money from
you while you have the money sitting in
your bank
so i want this to be a never again
moment where you say never again will my
husband's two favorite teams be in the
world series and we can't afford to do
it hey i actually george i think you're
right here's the thing this is me being
honest with jessica if you had paused
your investing
sold your home
and you were renting a small house and
not bought a fifth wheel that then you
watched a bunch of youtube clips you
could learn how to like redo it and be
cool and probably post about it
you would have plenty of cash to
send your husband to the world series
and that's a great gift i love it
i don't think it's a smart financial
movement the memory of paying off this
debt and being debt free forever is
going to outlast
whatever team wins the world series just
saying it right be debt free today watch
the game tomorrow on its big screen
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
if you've been paying attention to the
real estate market you've noticed that
competition between buyers out there is
intense
in part because the inventory of
available housing has been hitting all
time lows
now when inventory is low it simply
means there are more buyers buying than
sellers are selling
and that turns the pressure up on
everyone buyers want to snag the right
house sellers want to accept the right
offer this is not amateur hour
low inventory is here to stay
to win in this market you need a pro by
your side and that's why we find vet and
endorse top real estate agents across
the country called endorsed local
providers to help you
buy or sell our agents have years of
industry success and refuse to
compromise your financial goals no
matter how tough the competition is
good news you can instantly connect with
an endorsed local provider in your area
today just go to ramseysolutions.com
agent to find a ramsey trusted agent
near you that's ramsay solutions.com
agent and
i did this george and my agent was
incredible she's here in nashville she
taught me a thing or two she sat me down
once or twice and said i need to teach
you about reality and she was awesome
never compromised on the things that we
really wanted and needed in our budget i
mean she was awesome she got hey i got
to put this much down this is how much
house she was incredible she stuck with
us for a month after month after month
couldn't have been a better experience
i'd love to hear that a lot of people
are just hiring their buddy from college
just getting into real estate and don't
you can't do that in this market don't
don't don't all right let's go to sean
in las vegas what's up sean
hi how are you guys outstanding how are
you
i am grateful to be here um so i'm
really glad i actually found you guys
number to call you i have been battling
with this uh i feel like
i'm i'm battling with his blessing
uh we are currently on
baby step two
but my father has gifted us a house me
and my husband which is awesome right
it's like how many people can say that
um but so we're almost out of debt and
then we'll obviously be working on baby
step three and
getting our emergency fund but i think
i just we lose our vision after that for
what's next in our family and so
we were thinking about getting a second
house over where my husband's from which
is he's from washington but i really
don't want to pay the taxes of
washington if we got a second place so
we like the idea of 20 minutes across
the river uh into coeur d'alene idaho
um and
so we would like to say we have we like
the idea of getting a another house but
then we don't know
how based off of the dave ramsey
suggestions
do we get a loan on a house a 15-year
fixed mortgage do we
try paying it out right it's technically
considered an investment property
because it's not our primary property
so i think we just kind of feel lost on
with what to do with our financial
situation or not so would you rent this
house out or are you just going to stay
there whenever you guys are in town
yeah so we do both i was thinking of
verbaling it and airbnb
it and um
and also going into and obviously
staying there once we're in town okay
so this house has off like four days a
week he's off four days a week which is
awesome so we could go how do you get
that job yeah i want that job
dave makes me work
so he works three days a week
three well technically three and a half
but yeah three days a week three full
days three twelve hours here i talked to
dave about this yeah i don't know if we
can score that one john 100 so tell me
shawn what's your household income
uh we're at about 90
ninety thousand how much debt do you
have left
like uh four thousand
oh okay we're going to get rid of this
debt like what this month next month
no like in by february for sure why is
it gonna take until february to pay four
grand off
well because we also pay property taxes
which are going to be due in january so
does all of america holidays
i know so all of america but then we
have a
holiday and a holiday budget we're
trying to get people christmas gifts and
that's like a 500 budget
i have a child who is three months old
and she has a i have to make a homemade
formula for her
and it's really expensive
um
unfortunately like she can't handle the
she can't handle regular cow's milk so
she has to have i have to make her a
homemade goat milk formula
um tell me this what's your husband
doing the four days he's off
uh well he's also in the military so he
has um
he does
he does military uh stuff once a month
he's in the reserves
what does he do those other days
and then the other days he is a um
he's in school finishing up his
bachelor's which we also he's getting it
done for free oh nice this is in the
military that's awesome well thank him
for his service however
yeah you're welcome thanks you're
welcome i guess my husband he's pretty
great
um
for me i i then think about what i can
do i'm trying to actually start up my
own business on top of it
i'm working from home and so when i have
the time i
am trying to start so
you guys are are you paying a mortgage
right now are you in a house you're
renting no you got a free house are you
you're already in the free house you got
a free house yeah so you don't have my
mortgage payment
i'm still coming you have no mortgage
payment you have no mortgage payment and
you have no margin
i know and i we have no school debt we
have no are you guys doing an every
dollar budget right now
yeah i've been using every dollar budget
for like three years i'd be going
through that budget with a fine
uh pick comb going where is all this
money going you make ninety thousand
dollars and you don't even have five
hundred
a thousand dollars in margin to put it
so that's new so
um the five thousand thousand dollars is
or this ninety thousand dollar budget is
just started this month my husband just
got this new job okay so this should
speed up the business
this will speed up things it'll speed it
up but then you know what also recently
cut off the bills why we're not why
we're in the situation right now too is
we used to have two cars
we had a truck and then we had a four
runner and i had a loan on my for runner
and i owed like 16 000
and um i bought it new well that's of
course what we do people do that
especially with like you don't even have
a house payment you can this is like
your house hang on hang on hang on uh
let's get to the let's answer your
original question we're gonna run up
against the clock and the people who are
saying that they were right
yeah so as far as your actual question
yes it's not you can you can definitely
get a mortgage i would do it the ramsey
way 15-year fixed rate put at least 20
down if you guys can cash flow the whole
thing and pay cash that's amazing uh but
i'm not going to be mad at you if you do
it this way don't look at it as an
investment property right now because we
have no idea if this thing is going to
bring in a dollar yet just look at it as
we want a second home we want to do it
the right way this is going to be our
only mortgage payment but guess what you
guys can't even afford life with no
mortgage payment right now yeah so
that's what i'm more concerned about
yeah
you're dreaming about a second house
and you've got a three-month-old you've
got a husband who's working here he's
got a full-time job he's in the military
he's finishing backstreet well i want
you to slow down and enjoy
right now slow down enjoy the second
and get everything paid off and then get
a fully funded emergency fund and then
start wondering i wonder if we could buy
a second house and visit a few times and
just rent a place yeah when you're in
that place and then eventually maybe one
day 10 years from now you go all right
we're here enough that we want to buy a
place here uh that's what uh there's
there's just a lot going on here in your
life and like john's saying i think
slowing down is going to help you guys
figure out how to budget properly what
does this new income look like for us
what is the situation for our daughter
look like
i think there's there's too much going
on right now for you guys to even be
thinking about buying another property
yeah put that in a that'd be cool one
day i have a bunch of things like that
that it would be cool one day right like
making an album with me probably not but
going to a world series game that would
be cool i'll make an album with you if
it's a rock rack rock rap album rock rap
i'll be in for that i'm in not one of
your
sad acoustic records all right back to
sean's point hey that is a blessing sean
that's awesome get control of your money
so it can work for you not against you
and don't let the future this panic uh
should we do this that is ten years down
the road let's enjoy
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on the debt-free stage here in franklin
tennessee
alexa from staten island new york and
that can only mean one thing
what is it
i'm debt free that's incredible
congratulations alexa i'm so glad she
didn't scream at john i was worried
she's going to get her back i almost
saved the moment i almost set you up to
screw this whole thing up and i've got
i've got a gift for that okay so walk us
through it how much have you paid off
um
39
557.89
not that i'm counting every penny right
excellent how long did it take you 13
months
whoo you're getting after it okay and
how much were you making during this
time 75 000. except
you went all in huh yes that's fantastic
all right so tell us what happened
um so in late 2019 my brother um and his
wife uh were debt-free and they bought a
house and he was telling me oh like you
know all dead is bad dead and you should
work on paying off your debt and i was
like yeah but you know it's it's good
dad and you know i was getting an
education and all of these things um and
then a few months later i was taking a
bus trip to go visit one of my friends
and then
actually on the bus the bus driver was
telling me about his story and how he
like changed his life and he
paid off his house and he went back to
school got an education and was starting
to become a financial coach and it
turned his daughter's life around and i
was like wow like i should really look
into this ramsay thing and see
what it's all about and at least hear
hear it out and then um on the way back
from that trip i started looking into
the the total money makeover and just
listening to the audio book and
listening to podcasts and then
just hearing people's stories and
realizing it was possible i was like
let's give this a try so that's when you
know the universe is speaking what is
going on in your life
when your friends and family are talking
and then the bus driver turns back and
says have i got a deal for you like your
barista your mailman they're all going
yeah dave ramsey you gotta check this
thing out i've done a lot of debt free
screams and i've never heard somebody
convicted by their bus driver
and so how did you end how did you end
up with that conversation
i don't know we were just talking
he just said ma'am
have i got a story for you i don't know
i guess i was just talking about life
and he was like yeah like just all these
great things are happening so wow so
what do you do for a living
uh i'm an engineer for a cosmetics
company very that sounds awesome yeah
that sounds like a dream job so you
engineer the cosmetics
no no um i work on uh projects for the
the company to help with optimization
i'm an industrial engineer oh fantastic
so there was so many 10 words in there
john you got two phds you understood it
optimization engineering we get it okay
so what type of debt was this 39 000 um
so it had student loans car loan credit
cards and a phone
wow and a phone all right so you you get
done with the conversation with the bus
driver
you sit down and have
your total money makeover moment
in the desert and then you go home and
you actually look at your debts in your
budget walk us through that moment
um so i wrote everything out and i was
kind of shocked at how much it was but
once i broke it down one by one i was
it was easier to see how manageable each
one was you know 200 2 000 it was just
in smaller chunks versus you know 39 000
all at once um and then i just sort of
work worked on it little by little um
and i think what was really a pivotal
moment for me was like three months in
when i realized i had paid off like all
the credit cards and the the phone bill
and that first student loan i was like
wow like
this is actually happening and i can do
this you saw the light at the end of the
tunnel you're like this is working oh my
gosh and you're an engineer so you're
very mathematical you're like okay if i
just do this then do this and if i pay
this off i'll have this payment freed up
and you started to see the power of that
debt snowball that's amazing so what
sacrifices did you make what did you cut
expenses yeah you're an income you're a
fancy engineer surely your friends are
like what are you doing um so i cut out
streaming services i signed up for like
three different ones and i was like no
more
how old are you um i'm 25 today actually
oh my gosh number one happy birthday
number two
i i've never heard someone under the age
of 30 cut out streaming services and
still be able to breathe are you okay
yes
how did you know what happened in the
queen's gambit yes
social media and okay maybe some account
sharing oh wow
that's amazing wait so you were going
you said any expense that i don't
absolutely need is gone whether it's 10
15 20 bucks what were some any any
bigger sacrifices where you're like all
right i'm gonna have to shave this out
for a few months or a year clothes
shopping whoa i really love new clothes
and i was like no more i have good
clothes in my closet and you went
shopping in your closet exactly and it
was free that's great
brilliant that's incredible there's no
way a 25 year old cutoff streaming
expenses and clothing purchases that
just sounds very impressive yes you can
do it when you want it badly enough so
what was the why driving all this i mean
you just kind of stumbled into it but
there had to be a why
i think um
just growing up and uh i guess poor and
just realizing and watching my mom she
was a single mom struggle and just
realizing that's not what i wanted for
my life and i knew i wanted to like
learn and grow and you know make her
proud as well
and i think
just as i uh was thinking about my
future and building wealth and
eventually wanting to buy a house just
thinking about
i can purchase these small materialistic
things in the moment but
it was it worth losing out on wealth and
building wealth for larger companies
that are already wealthy and just
thinking about you know generational
wealth my future and just
my overall happiness as well in the
future how does it feel to be debt-free
feels great yeah yes on your 25th
birthday you realize you've won
yes it's incredible
incredible
well
george and i want i mean we're so proud
of you i wish i could go back and talk
to my 24 year old self and say what are
you doing here's what i want to know
what would you say there's a there's a
25 year old who's celebrating their
birthday today and they're going i'm not
cutting out netflix and i'm not going to
stop shopping but i've got this pile of
debt student loan credit cards car loans
you name it what do you say to that
person what is the key to getting out of
debt
i think the key is just knowing your why
and knowing your
your goals but i think it's just knowing
that your income is your biggest wealth
building tool and you can either choose
to give it away to netflix or whatever
else is you know entertaining you for
the moment but those things are fleeting
and netflix will always be there and you
can always go watch something later but
i think just really focusing on your
goals and just that consistency um and
then just using other things to fill
your time you can go outside uh i did
plenty of girls nights in instead of
going out for dinner and drinks and
stuff so john's a big fan of going
outside alexa you are an inspiration
you're his favorite
everybody and give me one more time how
long does this take you to pay off 13
months
i see some people that are sitting there
who are these cheerleaders who are these
people um so these are my friends ebony
and alexis
and in addition to them my mom was a
really big cheerleader
my boyfriend and i also wanted to give a
shout out to my uh fpu coordinators
jovan and paul
they were definitely integral in helping
me stay motivated and the bus driver
what was it i don't remember you don't
remember his name you remember the
stories he just lost to the east you
remember how people made you feel so
alexa from staten island new york paid
off thirty nine thousand five hundred
dollars in 13 months making 75 000
with some support from her friends
family and the bus driver count them
down your debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
what an inspiration john
and we forgot to mention we've got some
gifts for her today as well we do have
some gifts for you i should have told
you that we've got a copy of total money
makeover that you can give you can be on
the bus next time and hand it to
somebody sitting by you on the bus you
can pay it forward like it was paid for
to you and we got a copy of the legacy
journey
because you're only a quarter of the way
done and you have a long legacy to build
you've changed your family tree you've
inspired people around you it's
incredible
george look at this we don't talk to a
lot of 25 year olds i feel good about
the future which by the way someone
thought i was 22 so i want to let them
know that it's very kind 23.5 32 but i
love seeing people in their 20s who are
saying you know i'm not i'm not going to
wait till my 30s and 40s and 50s to get
rid of this debt in my life to figure
this stuff out she decided i'm going to
leave a different legacy and it starts
now and the word that kept coming to
mind when she was talking was
ownership like this is mine to move
forward i went and got a great degree i
am doing great professionally and now i
get to own what the next 75 years of my
life look like that's powerful when you
realize oh i can take control it's mine
it's mine it's my life i get to decide
i'm in the driver's seat i get to drive
and alexa can drive she's driving we'll
be right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong caller
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping with the
new promos they run every month you'll
save even more use promo code ramsey to
get the best deal today's question comes
from sydney in nebraska i'm 24 and i
have a bachelor's in graphic design i'm
debt free so i've been very fortunate
compared to many in the financial
department
however my work life has proven
immensely unstable because my college
courses never taught me how to work with
customers oh i've had three jobs where i
was let go due to it quote not working
out or the company did not want to train
me i'm currently on my fourth job which
isn't in the field that i love i come to
work on time i stay late and i work hard
but outside of a cashier job in high
school none of my adult jobs have lasted
over a year i love graphic design but i
feel like i found my passion only to
discover i'm not qualified to actually
do it because i can't connect with
people do you have any pointers on what
else i should do i feel like i'm in a
death spiral and i don't know how to get
out of it
ownership
ownership sydney
in this one little paragraph you blame
your school for not training you blame
your company for not training you
you say i just can't do that you can
george i see this a lot well they should
have done this and they should have done
that and i
i would have but they just could
ownership
you've got your big big girl and big boy
jobs now
you learned this you can connect with
people sydney you don't want to
first time you get fired for not being
able to do something you got a choice
george you don't want to learn this
thing or not
you said i don't want to i'm gonna take
another job
they fired you for that same reason so
then you said ah i'm not gonna work on
it i'm gonna take another job
and i'm gonna blame my school i'm gonna
blame my company it's on you ownership
there's a great book called uh avalor to
apple george it's i think it's demillo
is that demillo dimillio
um close enough yes
talks about having uh he used to run be
a leader in the one of the technology
programs at georgia tech which one of
the highest ranking technology programs
in the country back when we wrote this
book
and he started at having his tech
workers or his tech students
not take advanced whatever
for seniors but they had them take a
theater class a counseling class so they
could learn how
the story arc works they could learn to
interact with clients and with people
and so if you're out in the world and
you've got a job go sign up for a local
theater go see a counselor and say i'm
struggling with human connection can we
practice some things here so that i can
learn how to do these things
relationships are a skill human
interaction is a skill it's not like you
didn't
learn it and that goes for any
any job skill that you show up for at
your first job you don't have i have a
crazy i'll never forget turning george i
turned into a performer for a residence
hall
probably 20 million project i turned it
on a word document and i'll never forget
the president i who's a friend of mine i
handed it to him on a word document
and he was an accountant he's got a
wizard brain when it comes to numbers
and i'll never forget he looked at this
word document and was like
what what is this it was like had comic
sans font or whatever
and it i mean the way he was just so
dismissive of it because it was
obnoxious i had to hire
a
fourth year accounting major to sneak
into my office on wednesday afternoons
and teach me excel
because i had a skill that i needed to
learn to do my job right
and so whatever it takes learn the skill
yes yeah and that's one of those things
you're going to have to work with people
for the rest of your life unless you
find a remote job in a cave where you
can just design that's the only way
that's going to work out but if i'm you
i'm picking up a copy of how to win
friends and influence people i'm picking
up a copy of pat lunchiony's ideal team
player well he talks about how you have
to be hungry humble and smart and the
smart is not intellectual it's people
smart and that's why you say books will
help this person
fail your own cindy's got failure type
of failure type of failure needs to get
out there with some real people and
start interacting right these are this
is a skills deficit this almost isn't a
no almost this is doesn't feel like a
knowledge deficit as much as a dude you
gotta get outside what happens john is
this creates so much bitterness and
resentment over years where you go i'm a
really good designer but the lesser
designers are getting all the
opportunities yeah and that's not fair
and it's because they understand the
full picture
the books on the screen
oh gotcha yeah there we go yeah yeah
yeah adler to apple by richard demillo
yep yeah it's a great book and it's
about higher education in holland higher
education is spinning and turning but
one of the
one of the things just it's a great
author a great book but
all to say is sydney take ownership and
look at the things that your bosses are
continuing to tell you
you don't have these skills you don't
have these skills you don't have these
skills and you can blame them for not
teaching you or you can just go get the
skills here's what you said how to do it
thank you for that feedback and then you
go learn that stuff and you take it to
the next job and they go wow she's
really good with people that's just
natural
no she worked at it really hard but you
can get better at this stuff good grief
all right let's go to laurie in kansas
city missouri hey lori what's going on
hey guys um first i just want to tell
george congratulations on becoming the
personality i'm really excited oh thank
you laura you're the first one to do
that
and laurie they let me in and so the bar
is pretty low that's true i mean
but i appreciate that thank you so much
i think you're both great um so i have a
weird dilemma i
bought my house
last year in cash so i'm i think i'm
technically babysit seven heck yeah what
do you mean you think you're either a
millionaire or not are you a millionaire
no not yet
but she's on baby steps she's got a paid
for house all right you bought in cash
because you're a baller yeah
yeah
yeah so i'm still behaving like i'm in
baby step two and i'm afraid to spend my
money
and i'm afraid of making the wrong move
um i say like i hesitantly say seven
because i'm still saving for for my
daughter's college so i got that on my
radar and then i own a home and so now i
want to fix my fence because it doesn't
work and then i know i have a roof that
i have three to five years left on it
and then i have a car that has 217 000
miles so logic tells you any day it
might start to go out on me
frozen
yeah i'm just hoarding my money right
now and i won't spend it so i'm hoping
you can help yeah
who taught you this
who taught me the horde no somebody
taught you two things number one it's
all coming down at any moment be ready
and someone told me somebody taught lori
you can't trust yourself who taught you
that
myself i guess come from you you taught
yourself that well
maybe my parents there we go so here's
the thing
trust lori
it's not all coming down
you just paid for a house in canada how
did you even do that
hustled hard um i became the debt-free
um december 2017 and then i just kept
saving i mean that was the same
mentality that caused me to pay for the
house and cash is i didn't trust myself
to buy a home and what if i lose my
to pay for house in cash you did it out
of fear
i did well the end result is good yeah
it's good so what is your household
income i'm just curious
um my gross is uh 64 000 now
so you have 64 000 gross and after taxes
you get to keep every single penny right
yeah and i should also confess that i
still do a side hustle
and this it's crazy because like
all my money from my full-time job goes
into one bank account and then my side
hustle money is actually what i'm living
off of wow when i don't need to so can
you cash flow all of these repairs
easy
hey lori this isn't a money problem you
know that right i know
yeah this is this is a heart problem and
what i'll tell you is
the the longer you grind in this there
comes a point when um
your body will begin to break down
you can only be gazelle intense for so
long
before your body says enough's enough i
can't run this hard
and this may be a long-term challenge
that you struggle with for a long time
and it shows up in anxiety in other
places or in catastrophizing and other
things you do clearly do with your money
or it shows up in ocd in other places or
maybe all three
this may be something you need to sit
down with the counselor and say for the
first time
i'm worthy of being trusted and it
starts with the person i see in the
mirror or it may just be spend some
money take yourself out to dinner go on
vacation fix your roof you've earned it
you're awesome lori it's another hour in
the books i want to thank james childs
and kelly daniel the producer and
associate producer and george campbell
and you america for sticking with us
we'll be right back here on the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsay call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this is the ramsay
show where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your money your
relationships and your life i am john
doloni joined here by my friend george
campbell and we are taking your calls on
pretty much anything
and some would say the advice is worth
what you pay for it
venmo us
yeah you can it's good advice
tip your table let's do it because i'm
not been i don't even actually this
morning george my wife said
um
we have to pay somebody and i texted her
somebody texted me a venmo thing i
texted her and she said
um
it's the 21st century i i need you to
have this john is just john and 86 year
old grandmothers who are still writing
checks at the grocery store i actually
you are so like
anti-tech and i have privacy i have a
checkbook actually i thought that i'm
anti i
i don't know you know how mad i get when
i have to write a check john i'm like
come on what is this the 1950s i got to
find my checkbook i saw a blog recently
that just was talking to young people
about how to write checks that's how it
works and i thought oh no
i'm officially an old man yeah that and
some of my favorite childhood music is
now on the oldies station
that's how you know what's happening i'm
only 27. it's so weird it's so weird
anyway what are you gonna do about it
yeah yeah we actually included that in
our high school curriculum this is not a
joke we included a segment on how to
write checks
because students have no idea how is
nobody talking everyone's talking about
inflation and housing prices they don't
know how to do laundry though are they
not talking about check writing being a
thing of the past we're doing the lord's
work over here inside of the apocalypse
unbelievable
eight eight two five five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five speaking of crazy john let
me tell you this article uh came by my
desk as it does and here's the title to
this article man spent 150 eating every
meal at six flags since 2014 to pay off
student debt that's not great you know
what i love i love a good loophole
this guy found a loophole in the matrix
and he exploited it
oh a california man named dylan shelled
out a measly 150 a year to eat every
meal at six flags magic mountain in
order to save thousands pay off his
student loan debt got married and
purchased a house in los angeles and
that's the loophole he found out 150 a
year
uh year-round access to six flags
includes parking in two meals a day so
he went every single day for years and
got these free two meals a day
dylan genius
unbelievable i love a great killer deal
man
yeah um the other killer deal will be
uh his health yeah when he's 60 and he
goes to have his uh his heart examined
they're gonna say
this only could happen if you had
mountain dew and
um if you just had nothing but soda
and shenanigans for about 30 years and
he would say well if i got a story for
you he talks about this uh the first
year menu was kind of lame all you could
get was burgers fries pizza breadsticks
or a pathetic sandwich and a refillable
soda cup wasn't healthy at all which was
rough
uh so clearly he knew this but he said
to his digestive delight six flags began
introducing healthier delicacies to its
menu i i don't know that i'd call any of
that product
this whole article feels like an ad for
six flags new menu that's what it is
well for 150
for the annual for an annual for all of
your food for a year
to his credit he did live like no one
else he did that's that's like that's
like a few glasses of sparkling water
and uh a granola bar at whole foods 150
bucks man and the question is he lived
like no one else but how long will he
live
we just don't know
this is live like no one else for 11
months but it's john people are real
desperate to pay off student loan debt
and i i respect this guy's tenacity his
gazelles
so big shout out dylan call in with your
story we should have featured him in the
borrowed future documentary just
following him around
he's solving problems i like that guy
yeah triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to jason in
pensacola hey brother jason what's up
hey what's up guys
y'all doing all right so good
outstanding man what's up how can we
help
so uh my wife and i actually just moved
from cale's area we saw their house and
used the proceeds to set up roth iras
max amount for the year
pay off my truck so we are now
officially debt free awesome we've got
some extra leftover money
uh we don't know what to do with it we
were told maybe
um
mutual fund possibly
okay
tell me this do you have a three to six
months uh emergency fund of expenses yes
sir so you've got that
completely debt free you've already
maxed out your roth iras for the year
yes and we set aside money for january
to max out next year as well jason you
guys are crushing it
man what's your household income
uh between 80 and 90. nice and how much
extra money are we talking do you have
just sitting in cash
um
in in my account probably about
44 and my wife's account probably about
70.
just sitting there in cash how did you
guys save up this much money making 80
to 90.
uh my wife does not spend money
wow
she's the saver i'm the spender uh she
she has trained me well in seven years
um before george answers
you know i'm going to say this
or ask you this why do you got two
different accounts man
uh because she was with navy we're joint
owners on each other's she didn't want
to turn loose and navy and i didn't want
to turn loose in my credit union because
we both got
pretty uh
really really good
returns are not returns um
annual apr yields
on the same number over one
on checking account high yield checking
so who's got the higher yield
uh she gets
1.25
i get 1.7 so let me tell you for
a quarter of a point or half of a point
it's not worth the marital discord
there will come a moment when one of you
will spend something quietly or secretly
or i'll just cover it or hey i need you
to pay for that or i paid for it last
time i need you to pay for it
and that's that seed of dissension will
grow and grow and grow it's not worth it
man
combine your money why wouldn't she put
her money into yours if it has a higher
yield
uh because if i've got access to it like
i said she's a saver i'm the spender
there we go so she's worried you're
gonna spend the money
yes dude this is a much bigger problem
yes
be a grown-up jason
act like an adult
oh i'm acting like an adult i'm not
acting all right good one checking
account by the end of the weekend all
right george let's go for it so once
we've got that you're telling me you
guys have a hundred and fourteen
thousand dollars just sitting in a
liquid savings account
yeah well they're between uh checking
and savings yes
wow and that's a pretty impressive
interest rate you have on there
yeah and like any
we both have credit cards but they're
paid off regardless of balance every
month jason you're losing me man you're
losing me what's up with these credit
cards
just for cash back if i'm gonna if i'm
gonna spend the money whether it's off
my debit card you make 90 grand and you
have 114 sitting in cash you can give
yourself freaking cash back
what are we doing here man all right to
your question investing this money you
can put it in mutual funds you can put
in index funds to let this money grow if
it's going to be five years or more if
you guys are looking to buy a house or
something like that but otherwise just
keep it in those accounts until you know
what your next goal is don't go throw it
into the stock market and hope for the
best cut up your credit cards and get
one account jason quit playing around
with fire
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john dalony joined here by
ramsey personality george campbell
taking your calls on money on life
relationships mental health all of it
let's go to john in tulsa oklahoma hey
john what's going on
hey guys how's it going today
outstanding brother what's what's up
all right well actually my collection
kind of ties into the last college thing
um pretty much my wife and i got married
about two years ago um when we got
married we started baby steps did all
that made it through we're up on four
five and six now going through that
congratulations man
thank you very much um the problem that
i run into now is i want to get we never
did a honeymoon or anything like that so
i want to take her somewhere as a
surprise
how do i do that
since we have combining combined bank
accounts and everything else where i can
withdraw the money to surprise her
without doing on a credit card or
something like that
oh good good question what what kind of
gift are we talking here i mean you
don't tell me the gift i'm just going to
be listening
yeah well it's on a trip it's so it's
going to be airfare and everything else
something i can't do cash for i got to
be able to use our debit card to
purchase the airline tickets and stuff
like that so
sure so what kind of budget do you have
for this whole gift all in
the whole gift is probably by the time
we do meals and everything excursions
over there everything else probably
about two thousand to twenty five
hundred
this is a serious gift man
yep well we didn't do a honeymoon or
anything else so this is one of them
excursions big trees because we don't
treat ourselves so here it is so have
you guys agreed on what we think would
be appropriate for a birthday gift as
far as spending goes like is this in the
budget and she knows
yeah it's in the budget we've talked
about something similar to this and
everything else and i
it was
just going to jump and do it but i don't
know how to do it to do it as a surprise
aspect and seeing that we share the
accounts yeah you know i'll share that
one well there's there's a lot of ways
to go about that to where you're not
just using the debit card on that
website to purchase the flight i mean
you can do prepaid debit cards um and
things of that nature to where you could
basically debit that money out buy a
prepaid debit card with it and use that
debit card to then make all the
purchases for this gift that would be
the easiest one i had i've done a couple
of these john and i had i've got a buddy
my buddy todd will have bought some nice
things even when i buy christmas
presents i would send them to his house
um so that my wife and kids wouldn't
happen but for a physical gift like that
i had a buddy that would you know make
the concert tickets purchase that i
wanted to surprise my wife with and just
exchange it back for that very reason
there so there were some ways around
that i would be careful about opening a
secret account or something because
again yeah that's what i don't want to
do we're very open very honest with
everything and have it all laid out
there and we'll sit down and go through
the you know statement at the end of the
month and make sure everything's
budgeted out and appropriate
but a good surprise is so great man yeah
so awesome could you also just say hey
i'm trying to do this big surprise don't
look do not log in
i wouldn't do that
just for a week because you if you if
you whitney came to you and did that you
would look immediately a hundred percent
that's exactly looking under the
christmas tree exactly yeah but like
john said it's a and this is a trip
right so you gotta book a few things
there's some flights hotels things like
that
correct yep yeah you could use a prepaid
debit card to do something like all of
that uh with no issue so you shouldn't
run into any problems if you do that now
you'd be getting an expensive card so
make sure that you can get one that has
no to low fees um that's not hey we're
gonna take a percentage of the amount
but if it's hey five bucks you're gonna
prepay to get this debit card that has
two thousand dollars on it then you're
good to go and you can use that and she
knows the money's coming out she goes
all right there's two grand that came
out what the heck is that and you go hey
it's a surprise i don't want the amount
to surprise don't worry about it that's
what i don't want her to go well hold on
you spent two grand on what now yeah
that part you can't really achieve
do what
sorry about that what
so you're are you wanting to hide the
amount from her too
she knows with the amount but i figure
if i did the amount it's gonna be kind
of obvious what's going on of course of
course so yeah get get with a friend get
a prepaid card um the thing i would stay
away from is opening up a secret account
somewhere at a secret bank and siphoning
money off and
um that just feels like a stepping in
the wrong direction there yeah but i do
love the idea of a good surprise that's
fun man i'm pumped for that yeah good
for you guys all right let's go to cindy
in baltimore what's up cindy
hello hey cindy what's up
hi how are you outstanding how are you
i'm good thank you and thank you for
taking my call you got it how can we
help
okay um i have been given a financial
gift um from the passing of my parents
okay and i am trying to decide
if i should pay off my townhouse
or
should i just keep the money uh in the
bank because you know in 10 years i'm
going to be retiring and you know moving
out of state
so i don't know what to do um
the townhouse
it's in the community i'm not
real happy with
but you know with the housing market and
everything being so expensive
i'm not even entertaining the thought of
a single family home at this point so i
don't know if i should pay off the
townhouse
or not
and i'm really struggling with this
i'm so sorry about the lost appearance
when they pass away
um my dad passed away in may of 2020
and then my mom passed away in january
of 21. wow i'm sorry that's a lot of
loss in a short period of time i'm so
sorry
it is it really is yeah
so you've got this
how much is the inheritance
um
230 000. would that clear your condo
oh yeah absolutely what's left on the
mortgage
uh well we just refinanced for 15 years
at 2.25
and i we owe 130.
so you're still going to have 100 grand
after you pay it off
yeah
i'm paying that thing off today yeah
i know you get all this feedback from
people like you know no no don't do that
you know go ahead and put all that money
you know and invest it and i'm like i
know but i i listen to you guys every
morning at 6 00 a.m i'm at my job you're
on the radio on my phone on me and i
love that
so yeah here's the truth cindy there's a
possibility that there is um
a mathematical return that would be
against that would be higher than the
the apr you just you just refinanced for
that's true
okay
there is
an incalculable amount
of
of non-apr money i guess i'm trying to
say
for being able to wake up tomorrow and
owe nobody anything
and the way i look
at the gift your your parents left you
they were great stewards of their money
they were great stewards of their
daughter who they loved they thought
highly of you left this money for you
and so you can look at it as they left
me 230 000 that's one way to look at it
another way to look at it is
my parents parting gift to me was
freedom
i owe nobody anything i can take this
neighborhood and tell them to shove it
if i want to i can pack up and move if i
want to i don't have to pay anybody
anything ever again if i want to
and that to me is worth
a potential five percent return against
this two and a half does that make sense
which oh absolutely and and like i said
the only thing that's been holding me
back
is i'm not real fun i mean of the
neighborhood i mean the house is worth
more than what's owed on it i mean it's
actually gone up that's fine i mean it
doesn't matter if you love the town home
do you love the payment and so you can
use all that money and equity when you
go to sell it and get you something else
so i like the idea of you getting free
today i mean what an awesome way to use
that inheritance and you're still gonna
have 100 grand left over and by the way
that mortgage payment you are making
plus interest
you can now use to invest yeah look at
that
baby step seven where you can build
wealth and give like no one else and do
all kinds of things without a mortgage
payment over your head cindy if you were
gonna move in a year in two years
we would tell you to hang on
if you're gonna if you're gonna be there
for 10 years pay it off
because who knows what the world's gonna
look like in 10 years
so pay it off
wake up this weekend
completely
dead free walk in that grass let the
toes dangle out there they're going to
be asking why is cindy making uh snow
angels in the middle of the grass
because she's free be free solve for
freedom this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show and we are back
in on the debt-free stage we have
michael and ricky it's so good to see
you we know you're here for one reason
just what was that
to announce you're debt-free right
congratulations thank you
congratulations so where are you in from
we are from elkhart indiana beautiful
love it love it awesome so tell us the
story how much have you guys paid off
well our total debt is just a little
under two well 210. wow
210 000
all over 10 years yes wow so 210 000
paid off in 10 years in about 10 years
yeah a little less nine years in a few
months or nine years and 10 months 10
years is closed journey man you guys
have been on a marathon uh so what was
the range of income during this time
well when we started out i i was uh we
were bringing home 50 round 50k i work
as a nurse i was making 18 i was making
twenty dollars an hour yeah and i live
on overtime so as you can figure from
being a nurse
for a long time so was hanging around
50k for the 10 years uh no 50k was the
starting point our last one or our
ending point was around 90k last year
because at that time i was up to 30
options to the mid 30s
and again
able to go over that because i live on
overtime i don't think i've worked less
than 50 hours in 10 years wow way to go
so tell us about this debt what was this
210 000
well the 210 000 is actually broken down
between my wife's student loan duct
and
hey i brought a bunch into my marriage
so good for you and uh are the houses
that we had are first oh yes yeah we're
we're no house house multiple
well we went through two houses okay
like a starter house like we bought our
first house and we were there for three
years and then we moved and upgraded to
a larger house and that's the house we
have now so
we sold the first one and put all that
equity towards the second mortgage we
had and now it's all gone that's
incredible you all are officially weird
people we are what is this house
you know honestly with the way the home
prices are i have no idea what it is we
paid what was it 150 for it we paid 150
for it it should be worth somewhere
around 175 000 maybe 200 by the time
we're all done with all the upgrades
that need to be that's incredible so
what got you started on this journey 10
years ago well actually i started the
journey over 10 years ago okay um and my
story is a little bit different
um
with my story i had come down or i had
come down back down to indiana
and because of an identity theft issue
in my senior year of engineering school
it took me about 10 years to go through
that in the meantime though however i
heard about this crazy guy that hated
creditors even more than i was learning
to hate creditors during that time
um so
i got involved with that started paying
off my own debts
got found my beautiful wife insisted
that she take financial peace university
and go through the course before we got
married uh-oh he paid for it for me
because i was in college at the time
what a romantic guy what was your
thought when this guy's insisting that
you go through this course um
i was open to it i was like but i was
like i'm pretty good with money and he's
like well there's some really cool stuff
though about how to like like long-term
goals and everything and he's like i'll
pay for it for you i'm like okay well if
you pick
a true gentleman got your money where
your mouth is all right that is a guy
who loves you and that's a woman who
definitely loves you excellent
so 10 years 210 000
what were some of those sacrifices along
the journey that you guys had to make
especially in such a long period of time
to stay
motivated um
well
we i've always wanted to do an
international vacation he wants to go to
japan someday and i want to go to
australia and europe someday and a lot
of people are like you know let's go do
that for the honeymoon and
that's one thing we sacrificed we've
never done that international trip that
we've always wanted to and now we can
and we're gonna do it in a couple years
awesome right we were gonna actually do
it for our celebration for paying off
our mortgage but i had a baby four
months ago so there's like okay now we
gotta like put that off for like two
years because i can't leave a four month
old for three weeks with somebody a
baby's pretty much a vacation right of
course spoken like a guy who has no kids
yes vacation with no sleep
wow so did you have any cheerleaders
along the way in a decade of doing this
stuff
yeah kevin and sarah kevin and sarah
they went through the class and they
understood like why we wanted to do this
plan and what our goal was and they're
doing it too they're a couple steps
behind us but um they are definitely our
biggest biggest supporters is kevin and
sarah that's um our brother and sister
oh awesome
did anyone think you were crazy over
this period of time going wow these
people are just in this thing for the
long haul they drank the kool-aid
um a couple immediate family members
were like well why don't you just um
they're like why don't you just go on
vacation and have fun like you know or
or a comment of like you know you don't
need to like be that intense you're only
you know at the time with the 28 or
whatever when the comment was made it's
like you're only 28 like go do something
fun you know like you don't have to pay
off your house right away like
and it was like well they just didn't
understand how old are you you two now
i'm 33
i was born in 79 so he's 42. i'm not
that old he's making us do math john
just search my brain yeah he's 42 33 and
he's 42. so you're a 33 year old and a
42 year old with a paid off house
no debt in the world no no one can take
our house from us
a 90 000 a year income and that's only
because
you work a whole whole lot yes that'll
probably be leveling out a little bit
below so that i can have a life yes
exactly i did work some through that ten
years so
i have spent three years teeth or four
years teaching throughout that time
period one year we made 120 when i was
teaching and that was a one-time year
and you grew a couple of humans right
congratulations youtube two girls
you have changed
your family tree
i'm so so proud of you too so how does
it feel
no mortgage payment nothing
it feels really good yeah um it's really
nice because um like covid hit you know
like last year and the the one thing i
never thought would happen is they sent
nurses home
they said you'll come back uh when we
call you back and he was unemployed for
a month and i was unemployed for a month
and we had our fully funded you know
emergency fund and
um
like
so it's like knowing we were like really
close at that point like we it wasn't
paid off last year when cove would hit
but we were really close it was like
knowing that we were going to be okay we
had the emergency fund we were really
good with
our money making good decisions
and so not having a payment anymore has
allowed us to um
to do things like take fmla off and stay
home with our baby and
instead of actually
not meeting budget one month because it
was just pto no overtime for five weeks
instead of instead of having to pull
money out of our emergency fund we met
budget because we didn't have a mortgage
payment anymore oh it's incredible
encryptions that's what it gives you
options and freedom exactly look at you
guys and a vacation coming up a vacation
this is awesome
in both australia and japan easy quick
and easy flights from from indiana right
just a puddle jump
wow you guys are awesome thanks so much
for being all the way uh down here in
nashville to do your debt-free scream
and you've got two little ones you're
gonna bring them up yeah eli
so we got eliora and adanaya
yes let's meet him we got one that's a
long ways off long long ways off
well while we get him up here we've got
a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's absolutely the next step you're
already living that you're changing
these little girls legacy
and we also have a copy of the total
money makeover for you to pass along to
someone else maybe another young couple
who's going you know what we'd love to
have a paid for house one day and go to
australia and japan
so thank you so much for being here you
guys are an absolute inspiration you
guys ready to scream yes all right so we
got michael and ricky from south bend
indiana paid off
thousand
210
making fifty to ninety thousand bucks
over the course of almost a decade
you did it you did it you did it count
them down
ready guys
three
two
one
[Music]
that little girl right there with that
big old smile on her face she's never
gonna forget this moment and that other
little girl who is three or four months
old just happy to be here we'll never
know dad she'll never know that she was
even here but she'll never know dad
either oh sh they'll show her the video
a whole bunch of times it's on youtube
forever right that's right oh boy we're
so proud of you too congratulations
change your life start today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture of the day is second
corinthians 4 17-18
for our light and momentary troubles are
achieving us for us an eternal glory
that far outweighs them all so we fix
our eyes not on what is seen but one on
us but on what is unseen
since what is seen is temporary but what
is unseen is eternal
marie curie says one never notices what
has been done
one can only see what remains to be done
marie curie all right let's go to ian in
milwaukee wisconsin what is going on
hi in how are you outstanding how are
you man
um i'm doing good i
feel like i
accomplished like one of the greatest
things in uh getting through the home
screening process today so i'm really
pumped about that hey kelly is really
tough to get through man so yes you have
you have achieved something great
um so um
john and george i guess i wanted to
share um
so i'm a 36 year old a permanently
disabled police officer from wisconsin
so i i my injuries are all mental health
um i have a really debilitating form of
ocd and depression yep um that kind of
came about two years ago and were really
triggered by um
you know a lot of the stuff that i dealt
with at the police department i spent
a lot of time at rogers behavioral
health
but
after kind of getting to a point where i
can manage everything i got a full
retirement a disability
and two days ago i found out that
getting the national chiefs of police
association purple heart excellent
brother um
so i wanted to share that with you guys
um one because thank you um because you
guys talk a lot about
mental health on the show and i listen
to it every day
um you know but had i not followed the
baby steps um
you know even with a really great
retirement package you know i don't i
don't have to worry about finances
because i follow those baby steps and i
i think it's important that people
you know you never know what's going to
happen when you're you're 36 and being
on baby step
what am i on is it four five
i'm going to pay off my house next year
all right
no other
another debt beside that so
you know i i just think it's important
that people know hey anything can happen
and
had i not been following you guys i
probably would have added more stress to
you know an already traumatic two years
so i just i wanted to say thank you to
you guys and thank you dave and all the
listeners um
because you know it made the financial
part of my life a lot easier so i could
deal with the mental health stuff well
ian i wanna
you know what my dad was a police
officer and i spent a lot of time
working with police officers um and
shown up to
a number of those scenes that
will be in my head for the rest of my
life and i know you've been there too
and so i want to personally thank you
and george i want to thank you for your
service for taking care of folks in the
middle of the night when nobody else in
your community even knows you're out
there
and i want you to not
not not give up on ian okay
right
there's healing on the other side of
this and you've got a journey ahead of
you but we've got full confidence in you
thank you so so much for calling in and
for the shout outs but as we always say
here
um
man me and george are just
and dave we're we're just talking on the
radio you got you're the one that put
the hard work in you did the hard work
and you changed um your family's
trajectory man and i'm i'm just so
grateful for you thank you so much i
appreciate
i appreciate that thank you guys you got
it brother take care of yourself take
care of your family and um good for your
community for taking care of you
awesome the last 18 months have been a
lot haven't they george they have
somebody earlier mentioned a pandemic
which i hadn't that happened oh yeah
yeah a lot of worry a lot of wondering
what would happen next maybe that's how
you feel about your money too tired
stuck stretch thin
or you are like ian who just
man it is starting to really pile up on
you
and you tired of learning about money
too it doesn't have to be that way you
just need a plan because a plan gives
you confidence even when everything else
seems out of control and that plan is
financial peace university this class
will teach you everything you need to
know to save money pay off your debt
build wealth for the future you can
stream the lessons on your own or get
support by going to the class with
others i like to support i'm that guy
you're more of a streamer guy i'm a big
fan of the support side though being
around real people and being able to
have hard discussions and going oh i'm
not crazy i'm not alone you too that's
so huge that's something you don't get
from streaming it so i will say if you
can do it in a group do that then you'll
put up that plan to practice with the
premium version of our every dollar
budgeting app which i use my wife use
you all use that live at home big fan by
syncing your bank to your budget you can
easily track your spinning and see where
your money goes you get all this only
with the ramsey plus membership don't
stay exhausted and overwhelmed you can
win with money and it starts with your
free trial of ramsey plus text trial to
33789
that's trial two three three seven eight
nine let's take one more call let's go
to gabriel gabriela in oakland
california hey what's going on
hi i'm calling um
about a leaf vehicle that i have awesome
and i just want to say thank you for
your all of your help um and your advice
you got it hey we're coming up against
the clock here to make sure we get this
in before the show rolls over so get
right to the question
so uh i have a 2027 bolt
and i'm trying to
buy it out but because there's a recall
on the battery
um
they will not sell the part of me and
i'm stuck making the payments
and if i'm trying to get out of the
lease i'll have to continue to pay the
rest of the lease amount
so there's no current fix on the on the
vehicle
and um that's available
and i just don't know what to do and
it's wondering if you guys came upon
this before and if there's anything i
can do
to
get out of the leaf or purchase the
vehicle so they won't let you do an
early buy out because of the recall and
then they're saying there's no fix for
the recall
there's no fix for the recall right now
that's available i've never heard that
in my life i thought are you holding a
lease contract that says or a buyout
option
uh
i don't know
i would go back and look at your lease
contract a year ago yeah i'd go back and
look at your lease contract and say
because it should say here's the lease
and or here's the buyout option
and if they are not allowing you to buy
it out then they're in breach of the
contract
okay have you gotten details on what the
parameters are around this or is the
dealership just giving you a hard time
or the company or is this legit
uh as far as i know i've looked online
at some of the other um some other
people who own the vehicle and they said
they've had a difficult time doing it
there's been a few people who said that
they've been able to just calling back
and budging them but i've i've contacted
the finance company i've contacted the
dealership and they're just telling me
and then they gave me a number that i
could file a complaint
about it but that was it have you gone
down and to speak to somebody in person
no i was on my way to
to do that and they asked me not to come
in because there was nothing they would
be able to do yeah of course they did so
i would get a copy of the lease contract
and
highlight the portion that is the buyout
option it may have a clause in there
that says
if there's a recall you can't buy it out
um this sounds real fishy to me i've
never heard of this now i've never
leased a car either but i've never heard
of somebody being trapped inside of a
contract this way
and then the the owner of the contract
that has the buyout option cancels the
buyouts i'm going to fight them
and go i'm going to raise some hell
until they let me break this lease with
no penalties because they have to
provide a safe vehicle for you yeah and
so if that's the case
they've got to come up with a solution
this isn't on you when the recall is
just floating in the air and you're
stuck here with a car that has a recall
on it so i'm going to fight them i'm
going to show up every day until they go
we got to get this lady out of here man
fine fine we'll buy it out whatever you
need to do so is the value of the car
more than you oh what's going on there
um no it's about to see okay so be a
pretty even break and you can pay cash
for a car save up and do that later on
yeah i'm fighting them don't give up all
right i want to thank producer james
child and associate producer kelly
daniel
george it's always fun to hang out with
you last thanks for being on the show
with me thanks letting me be on your
show today thank you it's been great and
america
take care of yourselves be kind to one
another and we'll see you soon on the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
you